e briga na escola Engraçado é a
discussão Mas tu pegou meu adesivo
grande não foi Meu Eu eu eu foi não hã
foi não foi não hum eu eu acabei de
dizer que não foi tu foi não foi não foi
eu não filha da e o pau bem
engraçado porque ele pula o i das
palavras armário é armário armário Bros
Mario Bros Rosário é Rosário não foi eu
peguei isso aí não filha da olha no
meio dessas coisas aqui não viu eu tô
falando aqui agora tu me respeita viu
agora vem ó otário eles chegam para
perto do outro você pensa que a pancada
vai rolar ele fica assim ó
fica só rodando sem encostar um no outro
parece que a briga dele não é para
derrubar não é pra ver quem tonta
primeiro aí tudo se aquieta todo mundo
cada um vai pro seu canto um pouco da
vida para trás e começa a conversar
sobre o assunto viu botei foi medo hum
medo não é amiguinho dele agora